[Music]
nice Vanna is one of the most promising
German classical music performers and
one of the youngest I messed up the
second part let's do it again what's so
fascinating about this centuries-old
music catherine was the classical music
hasn't stood still at all because as
performers we always make an effort to
interpret it in the best way possible
and in as newer way as possible
but yet not knows its roots it's like
science with a soul and that's what
fascinates me so much from business off
Mitzie lady miss Moonglow professors in
the other the Teatro Massimo in Palermo
is Italy's largest Opera House by
appearing as a guest soloist here
Gnaeus Vandana we'll be following in the
footsteps of legends such as Luciano
Pavarotti the countertenor can reach a
pitch usually attained only by women in
a system endlessly these are the vocal
chords in a normal man's voice they
would oscillate like this as all but so
I only used the outer edges it is like a
mixture of the muscular memory that I
still had as a boy boy's voice that has
matured in a man's body
in Menna couples give it more
although Nia's Vanda ha is still
studying he's already won big
international competitions and he
conducts a boy's choir his professor
came to Palermo for the final rehearsal
before the premiere of Bach's st. John
passion he thinks that Mandela has
exceptional talent as a Twala as
movements are to begin with you have to
say that he has a voice with a nice
standardized that means plenty of tone
color his voice is not only very clear
and can be
heard over the orchestra it has
wonderful tone color good you could
compare it to a good red wine a little
velvety some tea this brother I bet that
he's going to have a fantastic career
spies inventors the moon glows like a
yellow rose nice Vandana is from a small
town in southern Germany but he spends a
lot of time abroad and sometimes friends
and relatives come to join him
Vandana was discovered at the age of
five when he was singing in a boy's
choir his parents had nothing to do with
music or theater but they always
supported him it's been Zell Horace's
I'm very glad that I live the way I do
and that my family is the way that it is
my parents have given me stability roots
at home the chance to breathe to think
about other things I'm thinking that's
very important to me I he posts his
selfies on Instagram as well as
information about other projects since
he's also a director and a choreographer
there's no contradiction between old
music and new media for Nia's Vandana
his solo performance in the st. John
passion will be one of the most
important of his career so far meant
Hamas's is my dream to be a successful
opera singer to train as a director a
successful choreographer and later to be
a professor and teacher the university
but I will always be a singer nothing
that's what I am that's my life I'm a
performance is a most add a Stella
[Music]
in this piece he sings about the
crucifixion and resurrection of Christ
[Music]
in the coming year he will not only sing
the st. John passion insights book but
directed to the next step in his career
and certainly not his last
you